everyone this is kevin from the test
website comm and today we are in Game
three of our coverage of the 2017
u.s. chess championships and we have a
good one today because it's the Battle
of the Titans
we have Wesley so antibiotic are wanna
number two and three ranked player in
the world so it's going to be a good one
we have Wesley so playing the white
pieces in Fabiano car want playing the
back black pieces once I show up won his
first game and then tied it around to he
has tied for the lead with one and a
half points coming into this round
Fabiana Caruana has tied his first two
rounds so he's going to be looking to at
least tie this one but you know
miraculously can always look for a win
that would be pretty impressive as well
we'll start out with so upon eforp on e5
Knight f3 knight c6 Bishop to b5 getting
into the Rui Lopez and then Knight to f6
this is the Berlin defense we've seen
more and more Berlin defense over the
past couple years a high level play even
if you just look as recent as the World
Championships between magnus carlsen and
sergei hijackin we saw the the berlin
defense four or five times in their 12th
game match he played this a ton when he
played vision on just something we're
seeing more and more common what usually
has two options here they could play
with the pond D three four most common
which is what so does is castle on the
Kings side and then after Knight takes
on e4 pretty much pawn to d4 is the main
move most of the time black is not going
down the line of the pawn taking on d4
I'm going to look over here to e1
pinning down the knight but I can't
really move right now so you may see
pawn down to d5 trying to protect that
Queen up here takes on d4 it gets into
some tricky situations that many times
black sisters won't have to deal with so
knowing that's going to be difficult to
hold on to that material
the most common move from here is Knight
to d6 now White has a few options from
here they decided to go down the lines
of the Queen swap variation so Bishop
takes on c6 but I can actually recapture
with his his B pond or D pawn decide to
go with the pond
on c6 from the deep on and then after
this pawn exchange than the Queen's come
off the board and so although this is
probably the most draws line in the
Berlin defense Berlin defense to
typically not known as the most
aggressive opening usually more reserved
jarash over the years we've seen a
little bit of ambition come up from some
of the lines but this one I would say is
more of the draw line it almost seems
like when you play this a you know
number two verse number three in the
world you're kind of looking at each
other saying well let's not get too
carried away there's a lot of other guys
here that we can win against there's no
reason for one of us to lose right now
that's the least time I'm imagining this
happening is there sitting across the
board from each other and this position
White has a little bit better pawn
structure but black does have
compensation and that his you know he
has the double Bishop pair is king can't
castle but that doesn't matter too much
when your opponent's Queen comes off the
board so all odds they both sides are
pretty equal in this position so
continues with pawn to h3 King here to
e8 Knight c3 both sides to continue to
develop a little bit more pods each five
so starting to push a little bit on the
Kings side of the board black does have
the pawn advantage on the Queen side so
using a look to make sure he dominates
on the Queen side and just somewhat hold
fort over here on the King side he can't
really push too much but he does want to
make sure that he doesn't get overrun by
the point on the King side that's really
the only weakness that he has right here
it's going to be difficult to really
control the center of the board there's
not just tons of pawns here so both
sides can easily just throw all their
pieces in the middle of the board I
don't see either side really dominating
that piece of the game here but Bishop
to g5 giving the dark square bishop
involvement of the game opening up the
door for his rook here from a1 to come
over here d1 control this open file
later on he can bring his rook over here
to e1 as well start to push up his EEP
on a Bishop to e6 opening up the door
for his own rook to get involved to the
action for a cure - do you want us we
talked about Bishop e7 offering up
trait if he wants to you know not the
worst move to go ahead and just exchange
right now so your opponent doesn't have
double Bishop here but serve decides you
know I'll go ahead and hold on to my
vision right now I don't want to concede
the drawl if you will so wants to hold
on to some of this material pawn here to
b3 just protecting this Bishop on East
six is attacking the pawn here on a2 so
wants to make sure you just have a solid
pawn chain on the queenside pond down
here to h4 this does in some ways kind
of lock down black over here on the
Kings side his knight does need to stay
here since the bishop and a knight are
attacking the pawn also the rook here on
88 for a while it's going to need to
hang out and protect this so you know
not terrible it does block off some of
the moves that you know white can really
make trying to get outside of this King
structure right here but all black does
need to play a little bit more defensive
over here on the Kings side as we talked
about rook to e1 just centralizing that
rook pawn over here to a5 this is the
one thing that black needs to do he's
solidified the defense on the Kings side
and now starts to look over here on the
Queen side of the board rook to d3
preparing for rook to d1 trying to
attack this D file and then just work
over here today says well let's just go
ahead and put a stop to this don't know
anything too crazy we do see an exchange
off the board and the Knight to e2 and
this is interesting I think rook to d1
is just a lot more straightforward my
exactly sure why you wouldn't do this
you always want to control these long
files you know work here to d1 King CH
we could see the bishop exchange on
board Knight back here to e7 we don't
need exact moves that they would do but
you know Knight to g5 attacking the
bishop and the pawn we could see in
exchange if we wanted to or just pawn up
here to F Forbes solidifying I think
this is a pretty good position for white
but you never know there's a lot of
these positions that they have computers
running tons of analysis they may see
something you know five times out of a
hundred in game they really like one
position they think they have an
advantage
and it all stems from this move Knight
to e2 not really sure how their teams
are preparing for this but Knight to e2
and Bishop to d5 decentralizing we do
see the exchange on e7 eventually so
what so so decides now it's a good time
to go ahead and get rid of that double
Bishop pair for Fabiana Caruana after
the Kings exchange that appear to d4 and
then we see the nice exchange here on d4
so we do have a you know rook and one
minor piece in game bishops usually do
well if there's pawn chains on both
sides of the board
nice usually do better if there's just
one pawn chain because it can just
control the entire thing right here but
both sides you know fairly even on the
board White's really going to be looking
to get all of his pawns and all of his
pieces really on dark squares so that
this light square bishop has less of an
effect on the game and black is going to
really be looking to kind of break
through with his rook right now it's
playing defensive but it doesn't have to
anymore there's not any more pressure so
you can play rook down here to h5 start
to attack the clonic play rook over here
to a8 and really start to attack the
Queen as we talked about since he does
have the pawn advantage that's what both
sides are going to be looking at in this
position
Fabiano now plays Bishop to e6 and then
pawn up to c4 and this is some other
than she move I think I prefer the pawn
up here to f4 and just really start to
attack on the King side of the board not
worry so much about the Queen side
because after pawn to c4 it's kind of
undermined just by pawn to a4
so you know small choices here and there
you know my preference but decides to go
and play pawn to c4 pawn a4 and then
upon up here to a c5 so getting it out
of way of this Bishop this is a nice
little square here on c5 does limit some
of the squares that the King can go to
if this pawn is no longer here and make
sure that there's not too much that the
pawns can do as far as pushing forward
it's going to put stop that right away
when you see an exchange on here this
Knights kind of tied down protecting
this pawn from the bishop so later on
you will want to make sure you place
on to b4 pawn to g6 from black this is
another one of those where you know we
kind of study this game and figure out
what options does he have right here
I think rook to a8 makes a lot of sense
it is the one you know open file where
you can get behind enemy lines the other
open file is the D file but he's not
going to get past this Knight right here
this Knight can't come over here and
block off the rook on the a file so you
can easily get behind enemy lines if he
wants to he can play rook down here to
a3 put more pressure on this pawn on b3
if you wanted to he could even come down
to the second rank always going to have
your rooks down in your second ring if
you're black so I think this is probably
the more aggressive place from five
marijuana but I played it a little bit
safer in my opinion with pawn to g6 I
woke up to e4 now attacking this pawn on
h4 Bishop to d5 attack of the rook rook
over here to g4 work down here to h5 so
taking a different approach here instead
of worrying about being too aggressive
over here just once wants to make sure
you solid over here on the King side of
the board pawn to f4 just solidifying
the pawn chain pushing forward a little
bit more on the King side rook back here
h8 a pawn to f5 seems pretty risky to
start blowing up the pawn structure
because I think it is a very solid pawn
structure but after the pawn takes rook
over here to f4 King d7 and then after
the rook takes a rook to g8 in this rook
here on g8 and the bishop are both
attacking this pawn on g2 so so is
forced to bring his rook back here to f2
and all of a sudden Fabiano has a pretty
strong attack this rook is just looking
down at this King that doesn't have too
much protection this King is more
centralized towards the endgame you want
to have your King more centralized not
at the back rank right here not involved
into the action which is the position
that Wesley shows in so although I think
blacks probably come out of this feeling
pretty good about the endgame Fabiano
rook to g5 attacking the pawn and then
King to h2 which is a rook take here on
e5 knowing there's no way to to hold on
to that much here
it is going to fall and so now we see
Rick up here to f4 rook to a g5 and then
we see an attempt to trade off and we do
see an exchange and then pawn takes here
on g4 King here to e7 so now it's going
to be about centralizing both of the
King's pawn up here to g3 and the next
move I think is pretty interesting if
Fabiana would have tried it he played
King to f6 and you know it's not that
what the game is about right now is not
these pawns over here he's going to be
able to stop them if he wants to it's
all about making sure that his opponents
King can't get into the action and so
making it as hard as possible to do that
make the longest path for this King I
think is the way to go which means I
think pawn to h3 is pretty interesting
because now if the King takes either
they're going to have to come back
around this way and waste a couple move
or he's gonna have to come around this
way waste a couple moves and then black
can just kind of dominate the turn of
the board or shirt to attack on the
Queen side he does have those options
but since we see King to f6 and all of a
sudden pawn to h4 it's a little bit
easier for this King to get involved
into the action
why does have a been a benefit in this
position also of being able to push a
little bit easier with two passed pawns
or one pass pawn and a protection here
on the G file so not quite sure I like
the King here to f6 but we'll continue
with King to e5 centralizing Knight to
f5 Bishop takes here on b3 h 5 and then
King here to f6 and this is this is
where I think black had the biggest
opportunity in the game instead of King
to f6 what black has to worry about the
pond pushing forward up here to h7 he
knows he's not going to be able to stop
it on h8 because he doesn't have a dark
square bishop but h7 is kind of the
critical square on the board right now I
really like pawn to f6 getting ready for
Bishop to g8 protecting the square here
on 8 7 we know that this pawns not going
to be doing too much the pawn ever moves
up here it's
going to be taken right away from this
pond doesn't matter if it's recaptured
he's not worried about this pond right
here and so you know how does white
continue right here maybe King to g3 get
involved into the action bishop up here
to g8 as we talked about Knight to e7
attacking that Bishop Bishop h7
we could see some moves after the the
knight comes back you know this is a
really good position for black and
there's not a lot of great ways for
white to continue he's not going to be
able to hold on to these ponds and over
on the King side of the board I think
he's going to are on the Queen side the
boards can have a really strong attack
but in the game you can see how much
different it is when he plays King to f6
because King to g3 and he just doesn't
have as strong of attack the king is now
forced to come over here and play
defensive where I think the bishop would
have already allowed him to do that any
would have had a pawn pushed a little
bit further up the board pawn to h6 King
back here g6 playing defense pawn at g5
why he was pushing more pawns up the
board a bishop to c2 attacking the
knight Knight to d4 bishop back here B 1
a king f4 centralizing a little bit more
and now we see pawn comes up here to f6
we see an exchange on board and then
Bishop on b1 is hunting down protecting
the square here on 87 but there's just
not much that black has going on in this
position right here pawn to b6 and they
decide that boasts both sides don't
really have a lot going on so we do see
some exchange on the board there's no
way for white to continue up more so he
decides I'm going to go and give up that
pawn and then after King to a d5 pawn to
c4 and we see a draw in the game so
although you know two titans of the game
battling it out that we do get a draw I
think they played a draw opening both
sides didn't take too many risks I think
if anyone was going to win this thing it
was Fabiano at the end of it I think you
had some chances to maybe have a little
bit better in game but both sides played
it safe but at the end of the day they
did have a draw played extremely well no
real mistakes on board
little tweaks that I think they could
have improved on I think they'll be
extremely happy I think this was in both
of their preparations and anytime you
play a top three player in the world you
can come away with that with a drawl
knowing that you have so many other
players that you can dominate I think I
think that's a moral victory for both of
them so hopefully you guys enjoyed round
three we'll have another great game
coming up at around 4:00 but thanks for
watching I'll see you guys the next
video